Speaker 1: Many of you have written to me
asking me to talk about the situation going
on in the country, Colombia, in South America,
and I want to start with that today.
The New York Times has a good piece from yesterday,
updated this morning, summarizing what is
going on there.
There are now at least 19 people who have
been killed in what are being called pandemic
related protests.
But more specifically, the protests are because
there has been a tax overhaul connected to
the pandemic, which has been proposed that
has turned into anger from Colombians about
poverty, about inequality, about economic
conditions, and indeed is The New York Times.
Now, Times now reports at least 19 people
have been killed, hundreds have been injured
during days of continued protests in Colombia.
Tens of thousands of people have taken to
the streets to demonstrate at at least proximally
against a tax overhaul, which is, as the government
claims, necessitated by a financial hole created
by the pandemic.
And the president, Yvon Duke, announced he
would withdraw the current proposal and put
together a new plan saying that this is a
necessity for the country.
Monday, the country's finance minister announced
that he would be resigning.
But the protests continue and the repression
continues.
And now it is becoming a larger protest about
poverty in Colombia, about unemployment in
Colombia, about inequality in Colombia, all
of which has been exacerbated by the pandemic,
as we've seen in many countries.
And I've talked a little bit about what's
going on in Argentina, my country of birth.
Incredible, anything you can imagine related
to the pandemic has happened in Argentina,
officials with vaccines in the trunks of their
car, their cars continued, inflation out of
control, overwhelmed medical systems, strict
lockdowns on paper that are actually not being
followed, in particular by the countries that
don't really want to use the term elite, but
upper middle class and many in the professional
class just living as if there is no pandemic.
So there's many examples Brazil we have talked
about, but this really sort of taking on a
unique shape and character in Colombia.
And the protests in part are continuing because
even though the economic proposal has been
pulled and will be replaced with something
else, the response from the state has been
extremely heavy handed to put it lightly.
And there have been instances of police abuse
captured on video.
I'm not going to play them because we'll just
create problems for ourselves.
One, one of the unfortunate realities, this
is an aside, but I think a relevant one.
One of the realities that we live with in
the United States is that it has for decades,
generally speaking, not been a part of protocol
to show the violence that takes place in war
when there is law enforcement repression.
And so we in the United States have a much
more sanitized view of what these of what
this violence looks like around the world.
And as a result of that, the policy is that
if we include a lot of the violent footage,
it's not just about demonetization.
Our videos can actually get blocked altogether
from from different platforms.
And so the video is out there.
If you want to go look for it, we won't be
including it in this broadcast.
But there are all sorts of videos of police
brutality video where young protesters are
seen shot by police.
There is an instance of a 17 year old, Marcelo
Agresto, who is a ninth grader sent out to
March with his brother, shot by police, died
after kicking a police officer, going by on
a motorbike.
And now we are seeing a sort of propaganda
battle that's also taking place between those
who say the police and the military are now
in danger and they need to be able to defend
themselves, a sort of tacit defense, really,
of the violence against many of these protesters.
And, of course, those saying this is a harebrained
idea from the government in proposing this
economic reform.
And then now that very same government, because
there has been an outcry against the proposal
that they made, are repressing protesters
and all sorts of video that has been removed
from social media already.
And all of the things that we often associate
with these circumstances in Latin America
are taking place now.
There are numbers that have started coming
out.
I mentioned already tens of thousands of protesters
and certainly hundreds of injuries.
The counter narrative is, well, five hundred
and forty police officers have also been hurt.
And there have been endless instances of property
damage.
And police say we've identified seventeen
thousand people who have broken the public
health measures because they were protesting
without wearing masks.
And so there is always a counter narrative.
But the big picture here is that much like
many other countries, a financial shortfall,
the proposal that was made economically would
have increased tariffs on all sorts of everyday
goods and services, which would make them
even less affordable for much of the Colombian
people.
And that caused an outcry.
And then now the protesters are getting knocked,
knocked around.
So we're going to continue following the situation.
All sorts of different Colombian news people
and musicians and actors that I follow on
social media have been actively posting about
this.
And not enough people in the United States
even know that this is going on at this point.
So that's the latest.
And these numbers, 19 dead.
There's a reason why it's at least 19 dead,
because in all likelihood, that number is
going to go up tragically so.
And we will have more about this maybe tomorrow,
maybe Friday, and certainly by early next
week.